this secretly filmed footage from a jail
in Ghana reveals what goes on behind
prison walls men share facilities that
can hardly be called toilet hashish use
among the inmates is frequent one room
is stacked with corpses these images
were all filmed by an undercover
journalist his name enlasa DeMaio on us
is widely known throughout Ghana but
hardly anyone knows what he looks like
one of the finest journalists we have in
this country he investigates and he
tries to bring out the truth he will
disguise himself he can consider as a
lady he could come tomorrow I see most
Lemmy could come Denise Diaz
even a madman he was supposed to receive
an hour back
I know if you ask him that he came to
malaria or not because the person that
came was a female today walking here I
wouldn't know I will never know him but
I know he's always around an ass
receives us in his office but we will
not show his face because he's made a
lot of enemies my journalism is hinge on
three principles naming shaming and
jailing so when I put this evidence
together I go to the court of law and I
testify before the courts and the bad
guys are jailed an ass assumes false
identities and uses a hidden camera this
footage is from the port of Tama Ghana's
largest with this method he has managed
to expose numerous corrupt officials I
do what I do because it rates corruption
of the society and make the society a
better place his revelations end up on
front pages of major Ghanaian newspapers
many people have been prosecuted or
fired from their jobs as a result an ass
has been honored with numerous awards
but there's a price to be paid for his
undercover work it makes your private
life a bit boring
because you cannot do what other people
do you can't go out and mingle as other
people do because of the security
implications my kind of journalism is
very risky it comes with all the traps
and threats and everything but I must
say I don't do this work alone I do it
with a team yes I lead it but there are
many names behind that means the word
possible and good his work has also won
recognition beyond Ghana meanwhile an
ass has embarked on an international
covert mission there's still much to be
done